top five favorite bands of all time even
and now listen you I know you have
you're friends with a lot of these guys
but so you got a really in Your Heart of
Heart top five band tied at number one
Smiths who who is tied with the PES mod
do you think the Smiths no no uh Beatles
and greatest song from The Beatles for
me she's leaving home that is a thre
minute movie The pesh mode Beatles
Beatles Tears for Fears oh I love tears
I just saw at the ball great Sergio
ah my all-time favorite song is masanada
and what's the last one the last one
is
maybe now Duran Duran I've seen them
recently a number of times in concert
and realizing what an incredible body of
work they have